Welcome to AV testing podcast your modern testing podcast your hosts Alan and
Brent will be here to guide you through topics on testing leadership agile and
anything else that comes to mind now on with the show hey we're back yeah
mostly anything else that comes to mind yeah and today's gonna be extra bad
extra bad extra yeah those of you that aren't in the I don't even know where to
start those of you that aren't in one of the three dot slack comm you can get an
invitation by going to modern testing org if you are there you will have seen my
post from a few weeks ago where I said Brent and I recorded no Brent and I met
and talked about what could have been perhaps the best podcast ever done by
anyone of all time and I didn't record I absolutely believe it was yeah it was I
mean so now now everyone welcome to episode 2-0 redo 202.2 could I do that so
yeah if you could imagine imagine like you've just listened to the most amazing
podcast episode in the world ever and then double it and then double it again
and that's what we had all or so we thought or yeah I mean you never know I
mean we'll never know and that's the whole thing yeah it's it's great big
bucket in the sky all right we have a male we when you brought up when you
brought up how to actually solve world hunger overnight I mean that was amazing
I know and I can't quite recreate it so one thing we did I wanted to re-mention
from the last so we're not gonna rehash it I did write about it on
anger weasel that sub stack comm I think but one thing I wanted to mention is
oh because I guess it's worth worth calling out in a podcast because didn't
get published last time after 200 and I also did it in 201 rather than take and
do a full edit of getting through all of our good blas and Brent's coughing and
this and that I decided I'm gonna try for a while to do far less editing and
just fix fix the levels add a little bit of EQ try and make a sound good and
then go from there and see how it goes and listeners let us know what you think
you can you have many ways to do that the easiest is John our slack group go
to modern testing org blah blah blah and we're gonna see how that works and
then I spend a lot of time taking the ums out and after 10 years and 200
episodes maybe we can just stop saying that as much I don't know just a
thought I died it's I'm old and in my habits I don't know if I can stop I
put filler words in and today's worse and I'll tell you why in a minute but
what do you think about that brain ready to go your cats here today the cat is
dead Brent's cat is next to him in a little bed on the desk it's great but
unfortunately the cat died I am NOT going to prove that she is not dead
because if I do that or mention her name she will immediately start fine
I can only and what I am seeing for listeners who don't not have video which
is all of you what I am seeing is a cat that appears to be dead I'm still not I
could either confirm or deny yeah she's been doing it all day I saw the cat move
I saw the cat move the cat is no longer dead Schrodinger's cat is alive so hey
man bread what's new what's going on oh my god oh what I did is it review season
again what happened oh review season was was what's what's the Oh God this time
you're stuck to the gajillion you're fine oh yeah if I could ever you know the
problem with the stock being at a gajillion is you have to you know have
time to go do something with it yeah so though it's review season and I'll just
say in terms of this is the first time since Satya has taken over that I got an
uncomfortable whiff of the bomber years and I'm like oh no those were the those
and the aftermath of those were the death of me like I tell myself all the
time look at the stock I go fast eat at Microsoft I'd be so much better off and
I think oh yeah but I'd also be dead so it's hard so that's that's rough man who
who did it and you want me to take him out so the latter part yes okay first
first I don't know yet I'll make a phone call I got a guy the but it just to
give you a hint like like the last two weeks on average been doing four to five
hours of sleep because there's there's a there's a couple other things happening
that have to happen at the same time as well and so thankfully the the the
review season part of it is is over for now we got a three-day weekend and if my
body clock lets me I am going to sleep all three FM days okay I will tell you a
couple things I was gonna count them I couldn't I can't count past one one is I
as I get older I have less and less tolerance for people who are jerks and
people who I would say are people who act stupid your behavior comes from
motivation when you act stupid because you're you're there's something about
being a jerk in there but I I it there was a time of my life where I could
let it roll off and for whatever I'm old get off my lawn whatever I just
cannot handle when someone is a jerk with the exception of if someone has the
jerk and they have some self-awareness about it but if they're just if that's
who they that's who they think they need to be then fuck them the other thing is
I was in New York the last as you know last couple weeks and I had a flight
back last night supposed to get back and settle around 9 delay delay delay landed
around 1 o'clock in the morning came home got four or five hours of sleep my
body said get up Alan it's 10 a.m. on the East Coast so yeah lots of coffee
lots of snarkiness throughout the day I have less patience when I'm tired and
here we are and the thing is actually I'm going to careful listeners mark the date
I'm going to say something nice about Brent oh boy shit it's I already feel weird
never mind I'm not gonna do it no I I think we both can be the grumpy old men
the stark you'll mean we can be pissed off but together we're better that for
sure for sure yes because you know some good can come out of this you know it's
it's the world is a crazy weird place and the and the world of work is full of
people who do not actually understand how to get work done and you and I are
gonna try and help people navigate through that hell I just thinking yeah
grumpy old man is up is one of my better skills I mean it's it's up there with like
occupying space all right we we got a thing we can I can kick off a
conversation here if you're ready to get into the podcast proper yep and okay then
well welcome back it's been a long break we were recovering from the episode the
escapades of 200 but speaking of which we have a question so that that makes me so
happy it does on one of the things we covered in the long lost episode from
last time that we did not record was Brent noticing my joy in having all of
my little audio toys to play with as we do the podcast and it's kind of do do
stuff live every episodes live that's really what we're getting at really with
me not editing as much everything's live everything's live coming soon to twitch
you don't know what's happening you know what we could twitch we could we could
the thing is if you look at the two of us we are made for podcasting for better
for worse I mean yeah yeah like at times I think we should both just turn
off our cameras oh yeah yeah but I wouldn't see the dead cat so on our slack
group which I've already what's the word talked about a couple times there's
another word there but I lost it Sean H has a question in our mailbag channel
he says finally getting the episode 200 thank you for listening to episode 200
hopefully you didn't start at one and Alan's calm I don't remember saying
this here to help my I do know what I want to talk about but and sorry for the
editorial here but I don't remember exactly what Sean is talking about but
you may remember but I kind of got the gist of it says an Alan's comment
intrigued me on enterprise change do you think you could discuss in more depth
your experience on how you managed enterprise level changes without
people knowing I work at a big enterprise trying to improve quality
mindsets and feel overwhelmed level of effort and potential will of those
resisting so so we've done that yeah I have no idea what we talked about no me
neither but I can actually answer the question anyway the fact that the fact
that I have the memory retention of a small ant makes no difference makes no
difference I can talk about this and I can answer this question and I can answer
the crap out of this question oh well and the thing is like I was about to you
know say the initial question again do you think you could discuss in more depth
stop stop okay that's it can you think you could discuss in more depth dot dot
dot for Alan the answer is yes and I've seen him do it all right and and on things
he knows nothing about and quite well like he could pass the I don't know what's
the Turing test for intelligence or knowledge I don't know I'm a bot yeah by
the way the the caps of things are getting worse I hate them so this one's
interesting timing wise because I just put together a talk kind of about this
and I'm not giving anywhere externally and doing it for a friend for an internal
audience and I will do it for your company for you know $10,000 whatever you
need I got a pay some bills all right so but the second part is I mean I want to
put his context in there because absolutely true since I work at a big
enterprise and feel overwhelmed level of effort potential will of those
resisting is because people are lazy and don't want to change yeah in general I
mean you know this is the hard part it's organizational change so let me let
me go into depth because this is what I love doing I love trying to change
people who don't want to change and because they don't want to change for a
multitude of reasons what are some of those reasons Brent Brent was writing
wasn't making attention you ready why do people resist change the number one
thing is because it's scary think ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
that's the absolute number one reason yeah it is and for and it's scary for
different reasons they're fearful for different reasons maybe this change took
my job away maybe this change will oh maybe this change will require me to
learn new skills I'm afraid I won't be able to learn them which roughly is the
equivalent of take my job away potentially it's just deferred maybe I
won't be as important anymore I guess maybe there I'll take my job away or
there's something a version of a version of that but keep going you're on
yeah yeah so you can jump in here anytime you want I am extremely
interruptible on this topic so there's a one of my books favorite books that I've
mentioned a crap ton of times in general and on the podcast is a book called
Leadership on the Line by Ronald Heffetz and some other authors whose names I
forget and in that book he talks about the difference between adaptive versus
technical challenges and technical challenges are the ones that are easy
air quote easy they generally have pretty well-known solutions or like it's
kind of stuff we encountered before if I need to go write a new menuing system and
I've written a menuing system before I kind of have an idea I gotta fit it
within the context or I want to write whatever oh I every once in all for fun
so I can still feel irrelevant I go query some crap from github using their
API I know how to do it I didn't know how to use GraphQL to reduce my request so I
learned that but pretty pretty much a technical problem no can figure it out
answers are on the internet I can piece of stuff together adaptive problems are
where the fun stuff is this is the problems that you and I get to solve
Brent it's it's complex and systemic issues they requires changes and attitudes
behaviors and beliefs the solutions aren't clear we often have to start
before we know what the solution looks like there are things like culture
change you know adaptation and even just addressing resistance to change so in
this book Heffetz I mean it's not like a blueprint and there are no blueprints
but he gives some good ideas for helping people change stuff and what he
says is that you will no matter what change you're trying to make you will be
able to find allies but you have to look for no matter what change you're trying
to make you will absolutely have resistors and you're gonna have some
group in the middle who are kind of waiting to see what everybody else does
and go along for the ride so how do you do that how do you how do you like
let's say let's let's pick a modern testing principle give me a random number
between one seven okay so oh we want to improve the quality culture of our team
and this is actually well rolled because that's actually what the question was I
should know I should I should have went directly to that one but oh well undone I
basically basically when I quote unquote rolled I basically picked a number from
what was remaining after I eliminated one five and seven because those are the
only ones I still have memorized okay and and again there's no video but Brent
actually made the hand motion of rolling a die which is pretty cool by the way when
I was in New York I saw reason I couldn't record last week when my daughter
and I went to a sort of a live D&D improv show oh fun it was hilarious it
was hilarious lots of audience participation cool stuff going on was it
was there like an audience was there like a DM and an audience member like
actually rolling the dice or so there was a DM and it wasn't actually like a game
it was a it was roleplay but there were points in the story where they had to
we had to choose what they did or sometimes they had to roll and there
were some great rules for critical feathers or successes they did a really
good job having a scripted you know comedic show with some elements of
improv in it so pretty pretty impressed nice so people with a problem heffetz
find your allies yes good you know just just kind of walks through it you got to
take a step back get to adapt assess you know just do a bunch of different
crap lots of lots of listening you know and and communication anyway lots of
tips in there what was it getting to no blueprint can't get there by yourself
but you have to you know we talk about experimentation and software when you're
trying to do organizational change you have to be even more experimentable
more of an experimenter do you yeah so maybe let's say okay equality thing I
want to get my devs to write all the automation if you're in a company you're
trying to get devs to write unit tests I'm sorry hopefully they can get fired
you can get better death let's say your let's say your devs are writing unit tests
but you but as you're led by the research you want to get them to write all
of the automation what we can say Brett before I go on well what I'm okay I'll
just say it say it say it okay so number one this reminds me and I don't know if
it'll end up being relevant this reminds me way back in the day you were
still at Microsoft agile was struggling you you actually had you did a an event
and you asked me to be one of the panelists yeah we have talked about this
event before this was yeah this was a a monumental event in the evolution of
Alan and Brent at Microsoft and in one of the questions because the so the panel
that Alan had done was us was a small group of people who who claimed to
successfully be using agile in in their business I want you to pause there I
want to give some more context okay so I ran this community of quality leaders
around the company and I got them together once a month I worked with these
great TPMs I worked with it was a cross-company thing we got them
together talking about a variety of subjects one of the things that's much
better now at Microsoft even I'll admit that I found embarrassingly funny at the
time was how maybe this is true at every company I don't know but then how a little
Microsoft would pay attention or regard anything that happened outside the walls
of Microsoft anything that wasn't happening at Microsoft may as well not
have been happening so I tried to like bring things like here's the thing that
maybe you've heard of that you want to know a little bit more about it
because maybe you heard someone on the bus all excited about it things like
that so agile was one of those so at that time which was years after agile
had been around so I put together this panel as Brent had described right and I
remember and so and this was this was a community of mostly testers and many of
them knew me because I had been in the testing community for a while and when
agile first came out I was on the same page as many of them had been at that
point in time around oh my god agile is the most dysfunctional thing ever that
has ever existed right and in some regards it was because a lot of dead
teams took control and they just the other thing that you didn't mention is
the dead teams that did go out and look at what other people were doing in this
space had decided that agile was an a la carte menu right yeah let's just I
think agile says don't do documentation we won't do that and we'll do whatever else
we want it'll be great right right we are now agile god yeah right in to which
Alan invented a whole new term fragile which to this day I still love and still
yeah sadly observe fucking ridiculous agile the now going back to the one of
the things that I remember for that to make it so that it's not a complete
freaking tangent is too late one of the questions one of the questions is like
okay how do we get people to do it and in essence I remember my answer which
was look if you go to your executives right at that point in time agile was on
the leading edge of the bubble but at least within Microsoft I mean it really
wasn't but within Microsoft correct as a whole it was like in that in that phase
where only you know people who aren't afraid of risk it was early adopterville
at Microsoft and and and people were like going to their executive and say
look internet says agile is the best thing we should do it and you look
back and I'm like okay you went to your executive and I'm sure you're
paraphrasing but you went to your executive and said we should do this
because you found a web page that said it's wonderful and we should do it and
you're surprised that they told you no shocked I'm shocked like well what's
funny is this complete tangent has somehow wound its way back to the trail
yeah I was taking the scenic route no that was great so if I hand you the
quality culture quality transition culture guide yep English Alan whatever
that thing is we made that shows like how to grow is a quality if I just hand
that to you this is great go do it people look at that and go um yeah great
thanks Alan and the foul it away making those things change is hard and and
again going back to what Shawn said browser overwhelmed with the level of
effort and potential will of those resisting and yeah it's a ton of
effort which is why you do a little bit at a time that whole concept of 1% better
every day works really well here so if it's getting devs to own more tests it's
do it a little don't say like this week you do integration tests next week we do
end-to-end after that you own it all no it's not gonna go that fast you have to
this is a line from leadership on the line you have to disappoint people at a
level they can absorb I have I have more I can add to that fire as well and
men so what you have to do I mean and the problem is that level they can
absorb is different for everyone those who are on like yeah let's do something
different you can they're disappointed of a little higher you can give them a
little bit more let's let's use you to walk the talk show me the example you're
my pilot group you're gonna try new things I'm gonna give you end-to-end
automation framework and you're gonna use that and we'll have that as an
example for when the other folks catch up these guys at the other end said
great it's okay your unit tests are great why don't we pair one day a week
on writing some integration tests and and we can get a shared understanding of
what those mean and get a little bit done you have to if you aim too high
you're going to be disappointed here cuz it's gonna be that's what it gets hard
it's it's never easy but it's easier if you target what you want to do based on
the capabilities and willingness of those people you're trying to move but you
have to go a little at a time brant you look very anxious to say something I
have a long set of things to say so I will I will mute and let you go okay
so number one so you mentioned this book for me the primary books that I learned
from and then applied and then tweaked for this for those who care first and
foremost is influencers influencers is is a whole series around how to think
about how to execute the change and I'll go into some level of detail and explain
how it fits in even with Alan's paradigm the next one is getting to yes which is
a negotiation book because a lot of the times it's it's around when when Alan
was talking about okay you're fighting against the jerk well there there are
techniques you can do to to change their argument in a way that then opens
the door and the third one is never split the difference which is another
negotiation book but unlike getting to yes getting to yes is sort of an IQ
version of negotiation where never split the difference brings in EQ which is
often even more important right if you can have a pure logical conversation
that's great you're probably negotiating with chat GPT which by the way is just
an AI it's gonna be easy for you to win that battle now when I go through trying
to institute a change one of the first things I will tell you is every
successful change involves changing something slightly in all three of people
process and technology people are gonna need to get trained technology is probably
going to need to change or written and then a streamlined process that that
bridges the two between these like if you create a whole new tech and no one
knows how to use it guess what they're gonna fall back to the old stuff now
the thing I like about the influencer stuff is they will break things down into
a six quadrant problem space and for me I'm highly analytical time my mathematical
brain got stuck six quadrants so imagine a two by three table with things that you
quadrants are fours okay I get you two by three go on
six I don't know what that one is I don't know it was 24 of them or I'd know
how to do the math too many numbers it's now important so I'm typing so while
you're typing Brent's books are a little more mainstream than mine I go a
little bit off the beaten road but I made a little face on influencers it's
it's I it's good it's kind of and not from my it's fine getting to yes is fine
both valuable it's kind of like reading for those of you that have read them
those two books from Brent are like the DaVinci code the mainstream serpis thing
if you want to read something a little deeper a little more meaning out of it you
can read full cold spindle all right bread what'd you find out I'm still
waiting for are you asking chat GPT I am yeah it can't count either man it's
gonna make something up it's calls it a hexagon but I'm like no it's stupid it's
gonna make we know it's stupid it can't it's not a thing it's good at when you
know this you know better Brent I'm just gonna go with fuck you Ellen it's six
quadrants that answer is fair and we're gonna take that answer answer is fair
okay all right now when I go and analyze this like number one is yeah it's
convincing executives is absolutely possible like I now do it all the time
because I have worked with them enough to know what it is that that kind of
drives them what kind of the kind of decisions I kind of think you know my
experience a lot maybe it's because of I've grown as well but my experience the
last many years is executives aren't the hard sell no it's it's it's their
directs and and and then I do not believe I do not believe change other
than culture change change through executive mandate does not work or it
works in a very bad way no so the executive I know I know that is where you
were going no I wanted to be clear on that you need to it's a it's a it's a
people thing and and you met and stuff you mentioned too but most executives that
I know of will not say yes they'll defer yes if executives say anything they'll say
no right and if they say no it's dead so now there's a bottoms-up approach a lot
of people try to do the top-down approach and that's kind of what you're talking
about oh if I can go to God and get him to add the 11th commandment then my
problem will just be solved it is it now going back to the the quadrants so it's
a two by three that you can think about and in and you can think about these
separately the first one I'm gonna go with the two like the very first set of
problems is okay what's stopping them from making this change is it motivation
or ability and that is an important thing right if they can't do what you're
asking to do because they just friggin don't know how and that's why they're
telling you know versus or they even perceive it to be hard which is usually
code language for I don't know how right versus motivation which is I don't
want to if I go down this path then I'm testing my own code instead of having
and sometimes it's a little of both or a lot of both right it is and it and if
you go through and think about them all and come up with a strategy that addresses
all of them you have a pretty good chance in here I mean all six quadrants
here you have a pretty good chance of succeeding in my experience and the other
thing that you want to do so now the three that I was talking to it's a two by
three so motivation ability but now the the cross grid thing rose right it's all
right the person that you're trying to or persons that you're trying to to
influence right what's their personal motivation or a bit of ability that
blocks this right there is science that shows that if you if you can propose
something that that hits their personal intrinsic motivations you have a much
greater chance of getting them to do it right or certainly you want to avoid
their intrinsic the allergies right then there's social pressure and then
they're structural but in structural social pressure is like use peer pressure
to your advantage right um hey if you can let's say you're on a team with with
three other sister teams and and your manager wants something done right but
one team just doesn't want to do it well if you get the other three and then start
changing the conversation around how we're all great except without
mentioning names one whole team seems to be slowing us down right no one likes to
be left out structural is structural changes or more things like just reminder
notes sometimes that's all people need like a sticker that says place the boxes
here or or static analysis tools that say hey are you sure you want to maybe
not static analysis I don't know what but it used to be called big red button is
what office uses a tool that says hey you're trying to push a PR and it
doesn't look like your unit test RAM are you sure right that sounds like clippy
for CI yeah yeah yeah yeah so what I have found now when we're talking about
social pressures and then you started hinting to this you do want to I have
found that if you if you start from the bottom for for things like MTP or in
this case we talked earlier about agile right you want to look around and say you
want to gather allies is what Alan said okay but in particular there is this just
fantastic term for the type of ally you want okay and that is the opinion
leader this is the person who if you could win them over they're going to
they're going to be a public ally for you this is one of those people that when
I was mentioned you know that one set of people are the ones that just don't
doesn't care see who wins and they just follow that you know the that Shepherd
you want to look for the shepherds and specifically target them and go and
figure out what holds them back how you can help in get them to a point where
they're open-minded might be and willing to try a few things out now of course the
trick is with that one is what you ask them to do you really got to set it up
to succeed so that they have a continuous experience of something
positive if you say oh go read the agile manifesto or go read I don't know
what's the agile manifesto for MTP I don't think there is one there isn't
what maybe it is MTP so thank you for making most of the points I was gonna
make so this is good good everything it's right and the way I put some of
those things just to reiterate is I talked about allies and the thing talked
about I like the way you said let me say I even wrote it down so I could remember
that's weird right it's weird on day it's people process and technology making
sure it's one or a combination of those not what you said that's my takeaway
and I focus a lot on the people side because that's the harder part but you
do have to balance it and it reminds me of the times like what's the best way
to get devs to make sure they're writing unit tests and putting them in CI or
sorry what you just talking about what's the best way to make sure that
Fred the dev is running unit test for HXN you make it automatic or so brain
dead easy it's harder to not do it you make it brain dead easy like from my
experience there's two things that you do number one you make it brain dead easy
for them to do it number two in the case they don't you reduce the friction
between what they did and it going to prod and you hold them accountable for
what's in prod and right and it happens all the time so we many many years ago
many years ago 2001 or so I worked with our development team on Windows CE to
help them learn to write unit tests and they asked the questions you'd expect of
a developer at Microsoft in 2001 they asked me things like if we're gonna write
unit tests for all of our code what is the test team going to do oh you know
what you know what that reminded me of what wait wait don't you know what that
really holds your thought that just reminded me of I had for I hadn't thought
about this in years and we didn't bring it up at 200 what to date is still my
view our second worst podcast ever I only know our first worst what's our
second worst the one where we thought it would be a good idea to do a
podcast any presentation oh that didn't work yeah yeah yeah they didn't like us
giving each other crap in the middle so whatever you know maybe now we can get
away with that people know us better that was like in the 20s or 30s we couldn't
get away with it but that was one of the questions that was asked okay if you
remember I don't remember dude I don't remember what we talked about two weeks
ago so anyway unit tests Windows CE if I think you worked on Windows CE a bit we
didn't overlap but doesn't it through Windows phone it doesn't matter we had a
the names don't matter all of our tests were contained in libraries DLLs on
Windows and run by an executable that could go find the test cases inside the
DLL and run them pretty cool pretty common way of doing it what so what I did
was I because I wrote a little wrapper application that could look it would go
through the functions in your code and create stub unit tests for all of them
and I just stumbled across the source code for it a while back it's it's
brute force dumb but it works so you want to write unit tests run this thing
but all you have to do is fill in the crap make it easy to get started then
they can expand from there you compare with them coach etc etc find ways to make
it easy to do I wrote a little bit ago about a CI system we wrote for that team
before we know it was CI was just made it easy for people to do the things they
were supposed to do I was on another product once where we wrote a test that
would run in the background as you changed code and that's kind of what I
mean if you look at what co-pilot does today it kind of looks at your code gives
you some ideas you could see that expanding and doing static analysis and
other things in the background helping you fix your code maybe even and this
probably somebody's probably written this somewhere but I'm gonna go ahead and
imagine it hasn't for a minute so bear with me an a generative AI could as
I'm writing code not only give me suggestions as co-pilot does search
through a bunch of different static analysis tools and find potential errors
for me and flag them and create unit tests for my code and run them in the
background on my code and let me know if I was writing buggy code as I'm
writing it probably somebody's probably already written that not a big deal
it's free but anyway we talked about pilot I think couple things you didn't
mention is once you get those allies you collect that data you can tell a
story you can you can you can use that because sometimes those people who are
lagging they just want the data to show sometimes they'll ignore it what's
really good is peer pressure so and what and the way I do peer pressure is
probably at least two ways I'm counting on my fingers you can't see them but
one is just to celebrate the behavior you want to see team X wrote a full
suite of end-to-end tests they're running and monitoring they run within 20
minutes if they're running on every build is great call it off for the team
they go oh wow people often people people gonna tell me I'm wrong that just
being recognized for doing something is a lot more than you know giving him a
gift card or sending him out to dinner giving him whatever people like
recognition depending on culture you may not so use peer pressure there um game
if I give people badges I'm Iowa I want to give people badges in github for for
doing the right thing I'm just I just gonna ask like did has my I was still at
Microsoft I would wonder can we get all of Microsoft code into github because
everything's so silent you're not telling me don't don't tell me any
secrets anything be kind of cool but I want I would so number one I don't think
it all is but honestly the where it isn't I'm not certain anyone really cares
yeah yeah cuz at the time when I left it was all in I'm gonna call it visual
studio team system and not Azure DevOps that's a dumbass name so anyway badges
are a great way people go to somebody's report check out their code to see look
at all the badges you guys you guys are the shit yeah and I guess was just two
things so celebrate the behaviors you want to see game if I and or find any
other way you can use peer pressure you can because that'll make it'll make a
difference lots of little things you know you just inspired an idea I'm like
no no because I was thinking you know if I don't badges sure but to me badges are
are honestly they feel childish but you know what that doesn't feel childish to
me that's essentially the same thing is achievements yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm
like you know what it wouldn't take much like ADO probably wouldn't wouldn't
agree to integrate it but it wouldn't because all of their stuff out of the ADO
stuff that we use at Microsoft is available in in public databases I'll
be there's nothing stopping me from inventing my own shell and you can and
you could allow people with your teams with a high gamerscore they're allowed
to check in on Friday I I mean putting their shit into an iFrame is like the
easiest thing on the planet I'm like that's an idea now of course the problem
is I have to have time to do things like that and exactly exactly hey we have we
have covered a lot of stuff and we could probably keep on talking for their
hour on this but if you have more questions you can shove them in the mail
big channel but I kind of think we should wrap it up there everything you
but after this one last code a bit that Brent wants to mention we can we can now
I was just thinking through okay so and I what we really did is answered you
know we answered their question at a strategic level like we listed off a
number of strategies around doing this right order of ignorance number four
they didn't they didn't have one we gave them like a method by which we're giving
them a means to discover what they don't know they don't know is there anything
technical like the way they they said enterprise level change so that to me
invokes I think they're talking about things like are in the quality culture
transition guide so not really they may need a testing for I know no not really
no okay it's people and knowledge people and knowledge it's not as good as the
real 202 but I think we did a good job you know it's it's it's a start back
it's a start and you know what if it's not if you hated the whole thing and
you're still well one if you're still listening it doesn't make any
difference we don't have any ads yet at least so nobody got paid and you paid
zero except for your time with this podcast if it sucks you know what your
loss but given that let me pause and mention that we are on audible.com and if
you really don't get we are but I mean I bet Alan doesn't even remember the code
you're a horrible at bad jokes so um all right so let's call that day he is
Brent I am and I'm not we'll see you later bye